تداعيات ازمه الطاقه بين اوروبا وروسيا
تشتد في فصل الشتاء
وفنلندا الطامحه للانضمام الى الناتو تدفع
ثمنا باهظ لمسعها
مواطن الدوله الاسكندنافيه يلجاون للحطب
كمصدر للتدفئه وهربا من اسعار الطاقه
ادى الى ارتفاع الاسعار بلغ سعر المتر
المكعب من الحطب الان 220 يورو بعدما كان
يتراوح بين 85 الى 90 يورو قبل الازمه
رحله البحث عن حلول بديله داخل منازل
الفلنديين لا تتوقف لا سيما بعدما تضاعفت
اسعار الكهرباء على المستهلكين من السكان
قوطه من خلال حرق الاخشاب نقوم بتسخين
المكان قبل ان تنخفض درجه الحراره الى ما
دون الصفر كثير من الناس في وضع سيء
للغايه وعليهم التفكير في كيفيه بقائهم
على قيد الحياه لان كل شيء اصبح اكثر كلفه
تهديدات
طاقتها من روسيا الان تقترب من الرقم صفر
امام وزاره الشؤون الاقتصاديه الفنديه فلا
تتوقف عن تحذير مواطنها من تكرار انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي
الاقليميه والمناطق الاصغر سيعمم فيها
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي مع تحذير
لمواطنين مسبقا
بتاع يوم المشاعل ومضخات الحراره والالواح
الشمسيه ثم اللجوء الى الحطب جميعها مشاهد
تعكس واقع ازمه الطاقه في فنلندا لكنها
تعكس واقعا اكثر قتامه لانه منه
الفنلنديون منذ قطع العلاقات في مجالات
الطاقه مع الجاره روسيا على اثر الصراع مع
اوكرانيا
علي السمان العربيه